only on CBS this morning we have an
in-studio look at the last
privately-owned painting by Leonardo
DaVinci the portrait is called Salvator
Mundi which means savior of the world in
Latin it was created about 500 years ago
and was thought to have been destroyed
the painting was long mistaken for a
copy of the artists work because it was
heavily painted over its restoration
makes it one of about 15 known surviving
paintings by the renowned artist and
there's more Christie's auction houses
selling this painting this month in New
York City it's expected to go for listen
to this one hundred million dollars
bidding they say will start at 70
million Allen Wintermute is Christie's
senior specialist for old master
paintings he joins us now with Salvatore
Monday good morning Alan good morning
standing here because accidentally but
it's considered the holy grail because
well it was long known to have existed
but it was known through copies and and
there are drawings for it by Leonardo
and in Windsor Castle but it had been
completely obscured by paint as you said
and it was it was sort of hidden in
public view I mean it was in private
collections but you couldn't see really
almost any of the surface and it was
thought to have been lost it is serious
questions about its authenticity none
really
it was as I said almost completely over
painted but once that was removed after
its rediscovery it was the quality of it
became very evident and really there
hasn't been any real question of many
paintings do now we finished very few he
was not prolific and he was exploratory
and and a perfectionist and he often
gave up what he had started so there are
only about a dozen paintings that are
finished why is it called the male Mona
Lisa
well it's painted around the same time
as modally as it's painted around 1500
and his technique is such that he paints
these things over a long period of time
so they pray this and the painting of
Mona Lisa probably overlap absolutely
absolutely I mean there's the enigmatic
smile there's the soft smoky folk sort
of shadowing in the face all of that is
very characteristic of what you find in
Mona Lisa's you already have interest in
this painting we do
we're working financial release form
that they can afford this oh well we do
a little investigation for tell us where
that painting has been held in a by a
private family has it it's owned by a
European private collector it emerged in
2005 it was it was found and cleaned by
dealers who then subsequently sold it
and so it's changed hands but it's owned
by Europe elector well we kind of went
to them and convinced them that this was
a good moment I picture that to be
honest we were looking at and trying to
think of ways to get to for a long time
because it's it's such a great yes it'll
go for more than 100 million dollars
well that is certainly my hope and yes I
would guess it will it's the people that
have expressed interest and by that do I
mean Oprah Winfrey what we'd like her to
come look at it
what significant art collectors people
who have an interest in Leonardo there
have been a variety will be in the
United States how about that well it
absolutely could be but it really anyone
could bid and it can go anywhere
ultimately but there there is only one
Leonardo painting in the United States
and the National Gallery in Washington
everything else is in Europe so it would
be it would be terrific if it stayed
here does it make you tingly Allen look
I have to say it does it is really
exciting I've seen it for a few years
now and every time I see it it has
tremendous presence and power thank you
thank you very much thanks for having us
really great to have you here